Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah, and
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. [music] So do the right thing.
Pause the video, click the link below
and donate for your own au.
How are you guys doing? God's side is a
loathome, reprehensible, contemptable,
obsequious,
odious cultural quizzling who has made
his name actually attacking Muslim
people in Islam. He's a Twitter guy. Um,
and he's been coming on these shows.
He's actually gone on the Joe Rogan
Experience a couple of times as well. Uh
but actually this time when he went on
Piers Morgan's show, I was surprised to
find that Piers Morgan was up to date
with at least some of the statistics and
was able to push back on some of his
heinous uh claims. Let's take a look at
what this man has to say and come back
and respond in kind. Sweetie,
statistically, most men are not going to
be rapists. So, even though you're
wearing that really alluring uh
miniskirt, don't worry about it because
it's only a very small number that will
commit rape, right? We wouldn't say that
to them. Or let me give you another
analogy. You and I have had young
children. The
>> No, no. The analogy I would use Yeah.
But Gad Gad, hang on, hang on, Gad. My
response to that would be that, you
know, statistically 83% chance that
you'll be attacked by a white man,
right? So if you want to get into
numbers and probability, yes, I would
not want I have a daughter. I would not
want my daughter to walk across a park
late at night, but actually
statistically she's far more likely to
be attacked by a white man. That is just
a reality in the UK. That's why that's
why well that's that's the statistical
reality. So the framing of this debate
when people try and say, "Well, look,
they you've been invaded and overrun by
radical Muslims. They all hate women.
Therefore, it's become a very dangerous
place for women because of radical
Muslims. I simply throw back statistics
which is 83% of serious crime in the UK
remains perpetrated today by white men.
>> Pierce, 96% of Scotland is white.
Therefore, obviously most of the rapes
that are committed in Scotland are going
to be committed by white men. It's this
little thing called per capita
adjustment, right? I want to draw
another analogy for you because you
didn't like the the rape one when you
and I were raising our children and had
to look for a babysitter. Now the first
thing we have to say is we have to give
credit to Piers Morgan number one for
knowing uh the official statistics on
this matter to some extent. Of course
the home office in the year 2020 which
is the latest report produced a report
talking about grooming gangs uh in
copious detail. It doesn't actually
mention anything about religion in that
report. Neither does any report that
talks about grooming gangs. It talks
about cultural background or ethnicity.
Uh, of course, we have the CSA report
which is even more uh fiduous in this uh
respect. You can see in the on the
screen here. And what's really
interesting than this is that the CSA
report actually shows that there's a
disproportionality
in the amount of crimes, grooming gang
crimes related to white people. So per
capita this man was making the argument
that per capita Muslim people are still
more than the rest. Now if we assume
that the majority of the Pakistani
community are Muslim which is a fair
assumption then 2% of the population
according to the CSA report uh is is
Pakistani and 2% of the crimes were
committed by Pakistanis which is not an
over representation whereas 83% of the
population is white and 88% of the
grooming grs crimes are committed by
white people. So actually his argument
falls quite considerably on its face. um
this this obse apple polisher for the
right-wing uh this loathome and
contemptable individual couldn't um
couldn't actually get the facts right.
He got the facts wrong. Piers Morgan was
able to pull him up on at least one
aspect of things but he couldn't pull
him up on the second aspect of the per
capita uh interrogation which we've just
done here. But actually let's just go
for the sake of argument and continue. I
mean what is this? This is called the
ecological fallacy. Uh the ecological
fallacy is where you attempt to try and
define an entire group by the actions or
the traits of some of the people inside
the group. It's actually a derivative of
the fallacy of division which is the
opposite of the fallacy of composition.
Um and the ecological fallacy here is
being uh committed by Gad even if we
assume that he's correct about the group
and gang statistics which was as we just
shown to be absolutely false about those
statistics because he's assuming that
because some people of a group do
something that that is the defining
feature of the group. Hence why he had
this hideous and erroneous and egregious
rape analogy which he made with the
Muslim people Muslim population in a
country and rapists in general. That is
to say if one were to say for example if
that majority of people that commit rape
are men it doesn't mean that the
majority of men are rapists. You see
this is such a basic logic that even a
child will understand it. So even if we
assumed yes that the majority of
grooming gangs crimes were committed by
Muslim people it doesn't mean Muslim
people are committing the majority of
that they are grooming gang members. You
see it doesn't happen in a by
conditional manner. So that's the second
thing and that's not even the case
anyway. So why is it the case then that
people are making this grooming gang
thing a big thing despite the fact that
we had what happened with Epstein?
the the the list has been published and
we have all these elites and uh Jewish
people and uh Zionist people and other
other races and other ethnicities that
can be singled out. Now, still the
grooming gang situation is being
targeted is because there is a concerted
effort from the far right to try and
distract from what the elites are doing
from what the elites are doing where
they're abusing the young ones throwing
them into pool of sharks and stuff like
that and that they're discussing with
each other on emails and that your
president for those who are watching in
the United States your hillbilly rich
hillbilliny president was part of the
Epstein files that it can't get worse
than that for you And yet you want to
talk about grooming gangs. The only
truth about disproportionality in terms
of grooming gang that I could come
across statistically was the truth that
in Rodale and Rotherham and other
specific towns in the United Kingdom.
Yes. In those specific towns that you
found a disproportionate number of
Pakistani people doing it in those
particular towns. But how comes if
that's the case and it's to do with
religious determinism or um ethnic
determinism that we don't find
Pakistanis in California doing the same
thing or Pakistanis in London. Forget
about going across the pond staying in
the same country. Pakistanis in in
London doing the same thing. Why is it
only a very select parameters that you
are actually looking at in order to make
your case? You're not being open and
honest about this group and gang
situation. But I commend Piers Morgan
for pulling this uh this odious
individual
with his invidious uh comparison,
discriminatory comparison with the rape
gangs up. He should have been a bit more
forceful considering the fact that I'm
sure he knows Pierce Morgan is he's a
Londoner. Gad and these individuals that
talking about London grooming gangs,
none of them lived in London. Some of
them might have visited London for a
couple of days and they have all this
narrative that they want to project upon
it. But Piers Morgan to be fair to him,
he lives in West London. You know, he
he's interacting with Muslim people. He
doesn't see what you guys are seeing.
And like everybody in the country don't
see what you guys are seeing. You guys
have a skewed picture of the Muslim
community in the UK. And that skewed
picture is because there's an othering
narrative that you must believe in to
victimize yourself and to justify for
yourselves why it is that you must
dehumanize Muslim people and that you
must um deal with them in a certain
manner because you can't come to terms
with what's going on across the world
and you can't even look at yourselves
and selfacount and with that I will
conclude.
You probably don't deserve to watch this
video. Your level is honestly too low to
watch this video. So feel free to click
away from the video. But for the few who
can handle responsibility, we're
building the only masid in a village in
Norway. First payment is already done.
Final 500,000 remaining. Huge saddakaria
waiting. If you're serious about Islam,
you'll pause the video and you'll click
the link below [music] to donate right
now. If not, enjoy the comment section.
with